[Music]
music has been a big part of your life
oh yeah and you started out as a banjo
player yes with Gerry Rafferty who I
always loved Oh Julie was lovely and I
think with a picture of the two of you
guys were in a group together oh yeah
the what is it the humble bumble humble
bums yeah and and you and and for
unfortunately Jerry passed away last
year yeah P well I won't go into why it
died of this kind of terribly sad story
but he died and I was in there I hadn't
been together for a long long time we
had fallen and stuff like that but I was
in Australia and he was in his deathbed
and his wife called me and said do you
want to talk to him and I said yeah sure
it's just well you can't is not really a
nut sort of telephone state of mind to
be context time and so we take a text to
them on his deathbed and the world of
people texting each other and in that
it's a very powerful situation yellow
well you know I've been in that position
myself yeah but I was trying to make him
laugh you know I was reminding him of
old times and and he was wrong and
laughing and we get carried away and
then I just get his wave didn't know
half this stuff I was texting over and
but we smoked to Babel once
you and you and Gerry Rafferty's smoke
the Bible well it was the sixties you
know you know the sixties doesn't just
explain everything I shot a camel what
it was the 60s
doing it you would have you would have
loved it yes I wouldn't give it up gone
to hell with me yeah yeah but in those
days you did these sort of folk clubs
and they were and you'd they would say
the fee
there's would be X amount of money plus
accomodation well that meant a coach or
the floor or something right so all in
this guy's house remove an old trunk and
I had some hashish goodness knows
haven't gotten my pocket
Pakistani black ashes you ducking under
the low bridges with this stuff and I
and I got a note towards the end of the
night and I said anybody get any papers
or skins as we used to see us cooler
guys nobody had any papers and I said
well I saw a movie once and it was a
prison movie and they were smoking the
Bible apart using the paper yeah yeah
page of the Bible you can get a
reasonable cigarette paper so the guy
who owned the house was up in his bed
drunk and I said I'll go and ask him
physical Bible so I was gonna drunk as
well I went into the room and I said you
you he was sitting up readings gonna
pissed you know I always remember it was
it was reading a book of Warplanes
you know those those books maybe
remember them was a boy yourself there's
long books yeah Jota sport warplane
silhouette yeah I'm glad someone else
remembers but that's what that was that
was this chosen reading he was sitting
oh yes was this trouble I said you
wouldn't have never Babel where G says
yes sure go Babel said you want it I
said I just won a couple of pages
yes sadly any any any particular pages
no no
I didn't really need you to find out
what happened after that
it was revelation
you